coming off a lights out outing six days
ago against houston taylor hearn will
look to have similar success tonight
against the mariners comes home and he
struck him out swinging on a high
fastball at 97 miles an hour so heron
wipes out the first battery of the ball
game now mitch henniger
on the button base head jason martin
will get it back in so hanny with a base
hit so hanigar gets aboard and that'll
bring up first baseman ty france
this one on the ground could be two
culvers in the second one on the first
double play milk
no out at second
hanniger is safe for banyas came off the
base
right on top of it with second base
umpire manny gonzalez well
wait a minute i think he may have
yeah you know the rangers are
challenging yeah i think they may
they may get this one to see if they can
see the same thing let's see what we get
oh wow i guess they have different
cameras that they're looking at two away
runner and scoring position so an
opportunity for kyle seeger
high drive right field big time carry
buh-bye
home run kyle seeger and amanda's have a
two-nothing lead 22nd home run for kyle
rvi 63-64
and his tormenting of the texas rangers
in arlington continues
and we get ready to take a look at
left-hander tyler anderson just coming
over from the pittsburgh pirates he'll
get his mariners debut in this ball game
five and eight record for the pirates
with a 4.35 era
on the button here comes dylan moore one
out whoa
turf monster got him that's going to be
a fine oh my goodness and he knows
we'll laugh about it because you're
certainly going to hear about it
i like that
everybody is laughing inside the dugout
crawford's laughing
anger is having a good time at dylan's
expense how he made the catch here's
charlie culberson
counting the swing chased it for out
number two now that may have been the
cutter that is strikeout number one for
tyler anderson in the mariners uniform
swinging a fly ball into left center
field calling for it jared kelnick is
there in the gap and he makes the easy
catch and that will retire the side hey
welcome to seattle tyler anderson one
two three bottom of the first two
nothing seattle leading and here's the
catcher cal raleigh called up on july
the 11th goes after a pitch up in the
zone and hits it out in the center but
right there for it is white that's a
great sliding catch to reel that one in
man look at the athleticism when he got
to that ball easy it's almost like it
went through the lights real quick and
he kind of altered his route to the ball
the middle of the order nathaniel lowe
and diapagnes and jonah heim
swinging a miss battled back to get him
second strikeout one down here in the
second good idea what he's been doing
lately and that's the fastball at the
top of the zone 90 to 93 miles an hour
but he just stayed right at the top of
that line so two up and two down and
tyler anderson has retired the first
five in a row swinging a one-hopper
right back to the mound taken by
anderson good stop by the new mariner
pitcher soft toss the first in time to
get hyme and that'll end the inning two
scoreless innings and dylan moore draws
a lead off walk here comes jp crawford
there's a floater out into center field
white coming on still on the run he
slides falls forward and the ball pops
out of his glove headed to third is more
here's the throw more dives he is
out at third base it looked kind of
awkward but he managed to recover pick
it up and fire it to charlie culverson a
one-hop throw
culverson with a nice job applying the
tag to moore
and that's hit on the ground to short to
his left kinder philippe he bobbles it
picks the ball out of midair and throws
to first in time to retire france for
the final out in the inning as we go to
the bottom of the third inning kind of
drops it down sidearm it's swung on and
popped up to third seeger is there on
the infield grass and he makes the catch
around number two so martin pops to
third base
swinging it's popped up
cal raleigh off of the mask he's in
front of home plate drifting up the
third base line and fair ground he skips
and he makes the catch off to his right
eli white pops up and with that it's
nine up and nine down for tyler anderson
and his mariners debut so adrian johnson
wasn't feeling right there he goes laz
diaz had equipment so diaz who was at
second base now behind the plate it's a
three-man crew the rest of the way
tonight johnson gone because of a hip
injury here we go our first look at drew
anderson a little big league experience
under his belt ground ball to the left
side backhanded by connor philoppe he
sets and fires and in time to get
parents for the final out so it's a one
two three inning with two different
ranger pitchers anderson has retired the
first nine rangers in a row here's
isaiah connor philippi
this one out to center field that's a
base hit and kinder philippa is the
ranger's first base runner one on and
one on that'll bring up adolesce garcia
and swinging through raleigh holds on
another strikeout for anderson his third
two down here in the fourth swing little
looper and right to the shortstop j.p
crawford out in shallow left center
field he makes the catch and that will
retire the side
jonah heim will bat now with the tying
run in a two to nothing ball game
here's a swing by hyman of flagler of
the left this is carrying well and this
ball is history
for jonah and he has tied the game 2-2
time homeward left-handed yesterday he
homer's right-handed tonight and we've
got a new ball game in the fifth we got
single for hanigar here in the sixth and
in the tie ball game here is the
right-handed hitting france
this one lined out to right field back
on it garcia leaps and he makes the
catch
hannigar had started and gotten deep
towards second and he scrambles back
ahead of the throw nice play by adolesce
garcia and wright wow that's a difficult
one to make i mean he timed his footwork
really well
that's a bullet off the bat of france
two and a board for the mariners in the
sixth inning
and he lines this one up the middle kind
of phillip is there goes back to first
double play well not the conventional
double play but a beauty nonetheless
getting over
garcia go ahead run up there at second
base so low the battery has struck out
and popped down oh two pitch and this
one lined it to left field that's a base
hit here comes garcia around third base
more up with a baseball the throw is cut
off and the rangers have taken the lead
50th rbi of the year
for nathaniel lowe and he's made it
three to two rangers now giving up three
runs over the last two innings
he'll take his lead but it's still good
to have him joe smith to take over swing
and this is roped deep into left field
dylan moore racing back on the warning
track dylan moore leaps and he makes the
catch implanting himself on the wall in
left field the throw goes to crawford
under first in time double play
dylan moore getting it done in left
field
to end the sixth inning well just a
sensational double play started by dylan
moore in left field spencer patton is on
to try and save this mariners will send
up ty france
this one hit well deep left center field
got some carry tie ball game
todd france ties this baby up 3-3 in the
ninth ty france ties it up beaver la
frost here in the top of the ninth
inning now the mariners three and the
rangers three we're going to extra
innings so here's kel nicole for three
grounded over first that is a fair ball
diving to it is low he comes up pushes
it to patent covering and they get the
out terrific play by nathaniel lowe
diving across the line into foul ground
on a ball that went right over first
base two outs murphy at third base top
of the order here comes j.p crawford
here comes the 02.
goes the other way big hit 4-3
mariners j.p comes through in an 0-2
pitch and delivers a huge rbi and the
mariners are in front in the 10th inning
and diego castillo is on for the second
straight day for the mariners and a
chance for his first save in a mariners
uniform jonah has never had a walk-off
in his fig league career
and this ball hit well deep out to ray
it is gone
jonah has done it
his second home run of the night
and he does get his first walk off the
rangers win it 5-4
[Applause]